welcome to Carnegie Mellon online for
more multimedia from Carnegie Mellon
University
visit
thank you for your kind comments a as
you can see they were so kind that I
started to cough I was all that is my
great pleasure to dedicate this to this
talk to Rick McCullough because of his
contributions he is a person who I have
so much respected for so many years
because of his pioneering work in
developing new types of conducting
polymers for their application in
devices for his starting a company that
I think has over 50 people in it now and
for his leadership at Carnegie Mellon
University this it's my pleasure to
dedicate this the this lecture to to my
friend McCullough you know I just going
through campus there's just so many
beautiful memories of people and events
and joys that I've had at Carnegie
Mellon as an undergraduate student and
who still when I think of academic
scholarship and when I think of having a
good time I think of bagpipes I think
somehow Carnegie Mellon is the thing
that connects the bagpipes do everything
else that it is it's such a great
pleasure to to be here and I very good
at looking at the audience and seeing
when people go to sleep I have many more
slides than I could ever show and so I
will look at you and if you have a
question you'd like to ask ask me during
the talk or if you don't believe
something want me to expand on something
please PLEASE interject any time you
want to and the purpose of course is for
us all they have fun at these types of
things now the talk the level that talk
is sort of inner you know I
on the slides a lot more detail than
non-experts would be interested in and
not enough detail that many experts
would like but I could if they have
questions for the experts I would be
happy to elaborate and with the what
I'll be talking about is basically
nanotechnology for fun and profit I'll
be talking about lots of different
things everywhere from artificial
muscles to indicators for vaccines to
solar cells to organic light-emitting
displays various ways of harvesting
energy if I can figure out where I can
get the screen on here we go the work
that I'll be described as done at our
nanotech Institute I work for 31 years
in industry so I both love doing
fundamental work but also equally loved
seeing fundamental breakthroughs that we
make being turned into products
I like applications but at the same time
I like to be able to predict the
mechanical properties of the skin of a
neutron star although that might not be
such a practical item now our Institute
was saying I hope I have the right
collection of yeah I do have the right
collection of slides the again what is
the nanoscale the nanoscale is defined
as physics and chemistry and other
processes that are biological processes
they're occurring on the scale of one to
100 nanometers
what is a nanometer it's one billionth
of a meter now that's one billionth of
anything is very hard to wrap your mind
around but if the ratio of one to a
billion is the ratio of the diameter of
a marble to the diameter of the earth
that's
still one I have a hard time wrapping my
mind around but at least it gives you a
chance now though I'm not really
qualified to make this type of
comparison a nanometer is one hundred
thousand smaller than the diameter of a
human hair the the point is that when
you go to the nanoscale you see
remarkable new physics and chemistry and
other types of processes nature's
recognized that these new processes
occur on the nanoscale and she heavily
utilizes them for her types of catalysis
for example now should we be afraid of
nanotechnology I believe that you know
there's there's anyone who writes that a
nano material has a biological effect he
gets he or she gets lots of press of
course many papers that are written
about no significant biological activity
is ignored so you know the the bias in
terms of what the public sees is of that
type and for any chemical there's our
health issues you know that have to be
determined whether or whether they're
what the risks are if there are risks
and how serious the risks are for
particular applications and I think this
is the same case for nanotechnology I'll
be talking a lot about carbon nanotubes
now carbon nanotubes you know many
people say they kill cells we've have
movie clips that show in our carbon
nanotubes sheets and yarns neurons very
sensitive type of cell types propagating
in a normal way having normal cell
lifetimes in growing much faster than an
artificial substrates and there's a day
seemed to love carbon nanotubes but
again the whole story is is not out for
any one of many
important types of nanomaterials and
even today our most commonly used
chemicals people find biological effects
long after they've been used for many
decades
again we focus a lot on developing
intellectual property in our Institute
we like to make inventions and we like
to see those inventions utilized and one
way to ensure that these inventions are
eventually utilized is to take them
seriously by patenting them and
patenting them very broadly
internationally for example I usually
write my own patents this this one is a
key patent which is really about PCT
filings says it's 57 separate inventions
425 plate
pages lots of examples lots of figures
on lots of claims the that particular
patent would focused on the synthesis
and application of carbon nanotube
sheets and yarn so I'll tell you a
little bit about that carbon nanotubes
individual carbon nanotubes are well
known to have spectacular properties the
individual nanotubes can have a strength
that's 10 times higher than for
commercially available yarns or fibers
they can have higher thermal
conductivity than diamond they can carry
a thousand times higher current than
copper even though they have far lower
electrical conductivity than copper they
have low density high thermal and
radiation stability well what's the
problem
well these individual carbon nanotubes
are like minut bits of string and how do
you assemble untold trillions of these
mighty bits of string so that the baulk
article a sheet or a yarn has properties
that are exciting well our first route
for doing this assembly resulted in the
world's toughest material
when you say a material strong you mean
that it the a large amount of force per
cross-sectional area must be polite
before it breaks on when you say a
material is tough it means that a large
amount of work must be done before you
break the material materials that are
very tough are of great interest for
example for anti ballistic vests using a
spider silk is very tough material in
fact prior to our work as it was the
known as the toughest material it has a
tough at the toughness of about 150
joules per gram joule being a unit of
energy gram of course weights we've made
carbon nanotubes yarns that have a
toughness of about 600 joules per gram
which is you know is a of course spider
silks about 5 times tougher than steel
wire and we are the carbon nanotube
yarns are about over 5 times tougher
about 5 times tougher than spider silk
and how do we make these yarns we we
make them by solution spinning we take a
mixture a dispersion of carbon nanotubes
in a liquid and inject them into a
what's called a coagulation bath this is
a mixture of polyvinyl alcohol and water
the carbon nanotubes come out of
solution at the same time as they are
bottling together using this polymer
polyvinyl alcohol so we are no longer
focusing exclusively on this type of
solution based spinning why not well the
problem is if you really want to harvest
the extreme mechanical properties
thermal properties electrical properties
of carbon nanotubes you really want
carbon nanotubes which are very very
long because every time you get to the
end of a carbon nanotube if the
the electron or the phonon has to get to
the next carbon nanotube and that
process the unlikelihood that process in
some cases degrades the overall
properties of a yarn achene and you
can't process from solution or melt very
long carbon nanotubes it's basically
solution or melt processing is limited
short nanotubes so the what we did is to
develop a solid state fabrication method
for carbon nanotube yarns which starts
with a forest of carbon nanotubes now
what's a forest of carbon nanotubes
while forest of carbon nanotubes I
talked for two hours right I just
realized that I'm talking much lower
than a forester nanotubes is think of a
bamboo forest
it's each the carbon nanotubes are like
trees and a forest a bamboo forest but
these trees are so narrow compared to
their length it's like having a bamboo
tree that's 1/2 inch in diameter and a
half a mile tall now Chinese researchers
had discovered that you could pull a
yarn from the side of a nanotube forest
but the yarn strength was extremely low
not useful usable we discovered if we
just did supplied an ancient technology
of twist based spinning you know
basically deployed this twist based
getting on the nanoscale spinning on the
nanoscale that we can increase
mechanical properties by a factor of
about 1,000 and as a result we're able
to make singles yarn two-ply yarn 4ply
knitted yarn knotted yarn we can make a
20 ply yarn with the diameter of a human
hair what is special about these yarns
well if you take any fiber
from the Kevlar the spectra fiber
they're used for anti-ballistic vests to
a wet noodle or a strand of DNA and you
knot it it will break it than not these
carbon nanotube yarns do not break it
knots now why is this the case this is
something this is an inherent feature
which were arises because of the
nanoscale of a fibers within our yarns
now if you look at this knotted yarn you
can see the radius of this knotted yarn
is about halfway about five microns that
five microns radius even though it's
very small about one-twentieth the
diameter of a human hair is giant
compared to the diameter of the
individual carbon nanotubes that are in
this yarn which are only about twenty
nanometers so the individual fiber nano
fiber in the yarn doesn't even no it's
not it it's so deviating so such a small
degree from a straight line compared to
its diameter
similarly the loop strength of our
carbon nanotube yarn which is the
strength measure when you have two
fibers that loop together is a little
degraded from that of the parent yarn
our twist based yarns are tough they
have a toughness comparable to that of
the Kevlar that use for anti-ballistic
best they're they're far firmest
toughies are super tough yarns that I
first mentioned about however if you not
Kevlar it loses the stuffed us if you
exposed Kevlar to ultraviolet light it
loses toughness toughness if you take it
to higher temperature to lower
temperature knew the losses toughness so
this the property mechanical properties
of our yarns are very interesting and
still far from where we will eventually
be able to
the a toughness of carbon fibers is
about 12 joules per gram if you take a
toe of carbon fibers and try to break it
you can never could break them you tie a
knot in it just break so easily again
showing its vulnerability to knotting we
can take these carbon nanotube yarns and
make intense lights from them just by
putting a nanotube yarn in the middle of
a cylinder that has for us that material
on the surface of it and a current
collector you get two different types of
voltage amplification facts one is due
to the fact that you have all the field
lines of converging on this filament but
also the filament has little hairs
sticking out of it and these hairs give
you a second type of field amplification
effect which allows you to operate the
lamps at low voltages here we can we
showed on barber who did most of this
work on bars Aki Dolph Ric and my mutual
friends our buddy
used these the carbon nanotubes this
cold electron emission sources in order
to make the static display we can take
these carbon nanotube yarns and make
them into super capacitors that we can
weave into textiles using the Martha
Stewart method we can I have high school
students who won awards than a major
Korean Japanese a Korean US
technological meeting because of their
using these carbon nanotubes in textiles
for providing sense a sensory input for
a possible application and prosthetic
limbs where the idea is basically carbon
nanotubes in the textile this is about
an example of the sense of the
artificial skin but where you have two
carbon nanotubes yarns that are in
opposite directions perpendicular
directions with act as little switches
determining the degree of local pressure
this is a the first
wolven carbon nanotubes textile it was
way made by one of our high school
students in last not this last August
but a year in August she wove it on a
hand hand loom
every time she added a line of carbon
nanotube yarn she only increased the
width of the fabric by the diameter of a
human hair
as a consequence and so the yarn was
very small in dimension but there was a
concept demonstration I showed you that
you can make carbon nanotube textiles
she made it by hand she made that much
over three days but on a machine you
know it's clearly a scalable process as
a consequence of this high school
students work Diane Chen her picture was
in science magazine my pictures never
been in science management
as in honor of George Jeffrey at the
University of Pittsburgh I call our nano
explores that George a Jeffrey's and
that explores when I was entering 10th
grade in high school I wanted I really
wanted to be a scientist so I put my
suit on went over to the University and
but it was a red giant rain storm came
down so I arrived soaking wet met
professor Jeffery and he gave me a job
working at the at the University and so
in honor of him what he did for me and
what he's done for other people we call
high school students that George a
Jefferies High School's nano explorers
are nano explorers have won many many
prizes they continuously last week they
for the Siemens competition may our
finalists instead of drawing out carbon
nanotube yarns from a forest we
discovered we can draw on a sheet I have
many funny stories about these sheets
but I won't don't have time to tell them
but it's very similar we pull these
carbon nanotubes out from the forest and
you get a transparent sheet this sheet
is an aerogel I'll show you movies at
the end of my talk illustrating these
the strange type of aerogel Guinness
Book of Records listed this the lowest
density aerogel as having a density of
about it's made by NASA
it's a silicon-based silicon dioxide and
a claim it has a density of about 0.003
grams per centimeter cube the density of
these carbon sheets is about point zero
zero one five gram per centimeter cube
half as much but these carbon nanotube
sheets have strength remarkable strength
the aerogel is a porcelain
but on a gravimetric basis these sheets
that we pull out of carbon out of the
forest which is down here have a
strength which is higher than the Kapton
and the mylar which is used for
ultralight air vehicles and for it's
stronger than the strongest steel plate
on a per weight basis that mean that's
why if these if the sheet is is
densified by a process in which expose
the sheets to a liquid allow the liquid
to evaporate the thickness of the sheet
is only about 30 nanometers and again
which is of order three orders of
magnitude lower than the diamond of a
human hair it's probably wanted to have
so little hair I talked about it so much
here's that carbon nanotube sheet
supplied here's the sheets being pulled
out of a forest
I have movies I could show you later on
here now as a picture taken by National
Geographic magazine the National
Geographic photographer wanted the gene
Bloomberg to be able to tear up our
carbon nanotubes sheet and we of course
wanted to apply our sheet in other words
put the strong direction which is this
direction of one sheet matched with the
you know a fog '''l with another sheet
but you can see here this June Beetle
Bug is it's being supported by this
ultra thin nanotube sheet the force that
the nanotubes underneath that each each
of these legs is supporting is about a
million times higher than the weight of
the underlying that carbon nanotubes huh
I'll tell you about that later on there
are something called intermittent
bundling and their big bundling it's key
for this process to occur and you can
see there's interesting scale dependent
go ahead it's very funny post-it note to
pull the sheet we take a post-it note
there's a heesu from the post-it note
and that the carbon actors become
attached to that you draw relevant to
the issue of bundling which is a very
important question and also ordered
notices that you can see very clearly
high degree of alignment but aligned
with degree of alignment is scale
dependent on very high magnification
scales you see a type of cell phone
instruction where individual going to
bundles go along and they provide other
nanotubes are going to make a self of
instruction the we can use these carbon
nanotubes even there they're so thin
they usually assemble them we published
a paper on using these and a few sheets
because they have transparency liens for
iron stripping or accelerators we can
make these carbon nanotube sheets so
that they are elastomeric it's a pretty
simple trick what we do is we take a
silicone rubber stretch it slap on the
carbon attitude
now allow the silicone rubber sheet to
go back to its original dimension now we
can reversibly stretch 100% the carbon
nanotube sheet without causing its
changing you only have one question for
he talked to me all last night let's
start charging a consulting fee this is
very important people want high stroke
artificial muscles artificial muscles
that marry in which I do a lot of work
the problem is people can you know
people can get a artificial muscle
stroke three hundred percent but one
electrode material can deform three
hundred percent or even a hundred
percent or even thirty percent without
changing its electrical conductivity so
what people do if they use an artificial
muscle materials such as soap in rubber
they put greases that are loaded with
conducting particles as on top of the
sheets as electrodes now the thickness
of the grease has to be a certain amount
or you can't use an electric so unless
you use thick silicon rubber you
your actuator staff artificial muscles
that will be all grease so I saw that
personally I have a bad sense of money
my wife says never try to begin with
right no one will ever laugh at the end
of the program there's a ABC news show
on artificial muscles and which there's
a joke and try to laugh at very few
audiences everything very quickly we
very routine recently a company called
tirsia discovered carbon nanotubes
provide very exciting and Tenant
materials for magnetic resonance imaging
apparently the reason that they do is
that the sensitivity and of antenna for
magnetic resonance imaging oceans of
square root and inductance divided by
the resistance and the square the
inductance factor seems to be
right here you see a mouse's brain you
see resolution of 250 micron diameter
blood vessel we still are here we show
the carbon nanotubes sheets being
wrapped up into an antenna the antenna
that we made was much less than actors
when we believe is optimal
but being would obtain this high
resolution at this point is very very
exciting we can take these carbon
nanotubes sheets and make that use them
as incandescent and tendons what's
excited about that Edison over a hundred
years ago use carbon or filaments for
life balls first of all the player this
is the individual nanotubes act like
little antennas so the light is
submitted from these carbon nanotubes
incandescent cheese is highly polarized
also the amount of mass per sheet area
is only about three micrograms since
there's more than thermal inertia you
can turn me she on and off very fast so
you want to for example instead of using
a shutter on an optical device that
needs very fast fast widget and October
polarized light this is a cheap solution
a Hahn bar has done an enormous amount
of work on
for solar energy harvesting and also for
organic light-emitting displays here
we're using not only the fact that the
carbon nanotubes sheets are transparent
not only the fact that they're
mechanically robust
but also the fact that we can to the
world function of these carbon nanotube
sheets and also the sheets are highly
porous that means that organic materials
can infiltrate into the electrode and
provide very high every high area for
charge injection either holes or
electrons again we've done work with
Scottish Rite hospital and the
University of Texas Southwestern
colleagues there and find that these
cells just seem to love to proliferate
on the carbon medications so in fact
starting to work with cochlear Institute
in Australia from the viewpoint of using
carbon nanotube yarns for making
connections from the hard electronic
world to the electronic world ionic
world of New Orleans in the body one of
the major problems in cochlear is the
segregation of the connection like
between Leeds and Normans
Texas has been is
and I say will always be the energy
statements please don't forget to write
down your Texas silence okay I see when
I'm not in Texas I always ask an
audience to write down Texas saying it's
because I love Texas so much I like
Saints women like money could buy you a
fine dog but only love to make the tail
wag we're wonderful now Ross Perot is
interested in technology sees an
opportunity to talk to him finding a
snake killing don't form a committee on
snakes
remember he was the person who sent him
a private army to get his people from
ideas out of our Iran so that says for
appropriate state and now you understand
that why my lectures are also very
difficult sometimes
now some will be into the energy
statement historical past men we had
pointing with the ground and we have
technology depending on the oil and the
ground up to the surface what it means
to be an energy statement future is
something very different and we are
working on many parts of this future and
for example the beginning of the week I
was just I was up into General Electric
and it's connected me more working in an
energy storage with gentlemen working
other companies another type of energy
storage aspect we work on waste energy
harvesting coalescing chemical energy
cells that take waste take temperature
differences electro chemically not what
do you think this one of the areas that
we especially their interested in sparse
energy processes energy conversion in
artificial muscles now we are carbon
nanotubes sort of surprisingly we
discovered a long time ago act as
artificial muscles in an electrochemical
cell and they do need this is work done
with John Madden we can generate about a
hundred times the force of natural
muscle that was comparing the same
cross-section of some natural muscle
carbon that accrues we can obtain twice
the strain rate the for actuation of
those displacements natural muscle and
the effects here you know they're
beautiful physics associated these
artificial muscles in terms of the
quantum mechanical effects and how that
depends upon the chirality of the
nanotubes but reality the physics that's
relevant for these artificial muscle
actuation is very attributable
you're putting charge on a cylinder that
charge wants to get away from each other
so that causes your Nana to to expand
the beautiful physics the quantum
mechanical effects are and logan recent
charges
which show you something reason the
question you want improved artificial
muscles if you look at that we have a
lot of people have lost their arms and
legs in the wars in Iraq and other
places and accidents and if you look at
the prosthetic limbs that are available
now this is a modern prosthetic limb
there he mechanically he looked as
primitive as ones you can find on the
web from civil war they have degrees of
sophistication other ways this
particular artificial control nerve
signal from them I met a beautiful woman
in Korea last years and they look very
beautiful from the distance but when I
got closer to them they seemed unnatural
one of us is still in the objecting and
I didn't do anything
but inside the humanoid robots inside
affairs and why was her smile and
natural because it takes about 30
muscles to express sadness or happiness
and she just didn't have enough muscle
to that region and so our carbon
nanotubes audience can be in a diameter
of a human hair they can depending upon
compositions that we use they can have
Giants probes that are much larger and
that's fractional displacements much
larger than natural muscle for the
carbon nanotubes The Strokes are very
small smaller than for natural muscle
but I'll show you movies and I better be
careful of timing because the timing is
close to the end of the framing so I'll
have to skip through a lot
DARPA came to me John man from DARPA and
he asked me to work on the problem is
indicated here this time it is a robot
it cannot play soccer it can get up if
it falls down climb stairs it however
intense physical activity can only power
itself for 30 minutes before the battery
has to be recharged and when charging
the battery takes about four hours so
the point is the amount of energy that
you could store in a artificial muscle I
met in a electrically a battery is very
small compared to the amount of energy
that you can store or fuels such as
ethanol or such as hydrogen so what joy
main asked me to do because he knew we
were to discover a number of new types
of artificial muscles he said he wanted
be our team who develop chemically
powered artificial muscles in a robotic
soldier that could fight ahead of
American soldier take the bullets for
the American soldier and then drink a
shot of alcohol in order to fight on so
again you know we we have two ways of
making these fuel our artificial muscles
that first of all the first for once of
a dark of program you can't sleep in the
morning because you haven't gotten any
results and they really depend upon the
results of fuel pirate artificial muscle
and one type of artificial muscle the
each electrode in electrochemical cell
acts as a fuel cell electrode acts as a
super capacitor electrode for storing
electrical energy that's charge and is
an artificial muscle actually electrode
for using changes and shut the charge
story to cause some initial changes that
in the long term might be the most
exciting type in the muscle future but
at the present time our hosts are my
artificial muscle is filled hardly gives
the highest performance is just very
very simple it's not so academic
interesting practically very interesting
this and that is to use cart just take
up shape-memory wires coat them with
catalyst nanoparticle you impose this
shape memory wire catalyst the proper
mixture of oxygen and air and even a
diffraction is it eat something you take
away the oxygen and fuel expand again
I'll shouldn't be moving on that and I'm
almost finished Hawking so now these
fuel powder artificial muscles can
generate about 500 times the stress per
force per unit area five times five
hundred times higher force per unit area
than can natural muscles if you coil the
shape-memory wires into a spring through
some of this force capability but you're
able to get actually the ropes which are
much larger than natural muscle in total
the overall effect is we can each
actuator stroke we can get about a
hundred times the work Faculty of
natural muscle Alan McDonald is one of
my best friends in the world who
recently died used to say Sciences
people here's our artificial muscles
tales from the crane currently China
Korea China US Philippines u.s. u.s. New
Zealand now when they dharmic just the
last few moments I'd like to talk about
a technology which I first conceived a
long long time ago
but which we're still working on
improving at the University of Texas at
Dallas with a company called tectonic
this is a product which is longer than
commercial it's a technology that's long
been saving lives and it's a chemical
that is is formulated as an ink and this
chemical causes is a diatomic molecule
which in the solid state and controlled
by the crystal structure which it finds
itself is polarizing and this
polymerization result in long conjugated
chain which have about the same diameter
as a carbon nanotube
have two dimensional mobilizations it's
like for carbon magnitude but these
coverings romantic cover changes we use
to measure the integrated effect of time
and temperature in the same way as
integrating
temperature effects color quality so
basically we're matching activation
energies for the indicator device with
activation energies for perishable such
as vaccine again the indicator device I
have a movie which I'm ENGLISH will show
you narrated by private Brad Pitt which
shows our indicators being used in the
field so basically this is a color
outside just a color matching selling
these are these time temperature
indicators are used for all the meals
ready to eat that are distributed by on
our course our army over one point over
two billion of these indicators have
been so far distributed around the world
the World Health Organization
organization and associated agency path
estimates that these indicators will
save over a hundred forty thousand lives
and over the next ten years so very
proud of this particularly development
I'd like to just show you a few movies
and at the very end we still have time
maybe three minutes
I don't sliding is done in three minutes
time
I'll show you one on that fuel powered
muscles but remember you see you'll see
things going not too fast remember all
we're doing is we're spraying methanol
in air on these shape-memory wires
museum contract you'll see one that
oscillates well when it it stops being
heated because a plunger is coming up
and a funnel but then as soon as the
starts cooling the air start and the
fuel and air starting
heat up the actually there so it's it's
not a fast no on/off which is just a
question of controlling fuel we have the
carbon nanotubes sheets in yarns the
fuel powered muscles and the super tough
materials have been very popular with
the newsmen especially TV now just show
you one movie from
here's one on the Supertop that's still
now remember I'm depending upon unit lab
this armwrestling robot may perform like
a weakling but it's not made with the
hydraulics or gears that power most of
today's big strong machines the robots
losing this competition used artificial
muscles the sciences best attempt to
mimic natural muscles but University of
Texas at Dallas researcher Raymond I
thought we won't have the upper hand for
long his team have developed artificial
muscles that should put any he men to
shave these artificial muscles are able
to do over a hundred times more work per
cycle than a natural muscle they're 100
times stronger than natural muscle most
robotic muscles are powered by an
electrical current
but Bachmann's muscles are made of an
elastic metal called shape memory wire
and as he reported in the journal
science like human muscle is powered by
fuel in this lab demonstration the fuel
is alcohol it reacts with oxygen in the
air and causes the artificial muscle to
heat on and contract then they contract
by a large amount this contraction is
like the contraction of our muscles in
our body the muscles then expand when
the alcohol is shut off Bachman who
works with funding from the military
says these muscles could power
everything from artificial limbs and
hearts to super muscles for astronauts
or soldiers and maybe even self
sufficient robotic androids and more
humor aside perhaps in a very distant
future the humanoid robot who is sitting
next to you in a bar might be drinking
alcohol in order to work the next day by
then
I hear again I know the kinds if I just
show you about this is the sheet that
should be an example of a sheep being
drawn slowly this is a sheep being drawn
slowly and then I'll show you one to be
drawn at 30 meters per minute these
carbon nanotubes are sheets and arms
aren't very high commercializing a
technology here you see the post-it note
4 yards can prefer would be to place
lead-up to smoke going up in court as
long again the people draw more of one
hears that Jordan the Sheikh think are
all fast
this is that being drawn at about 30
meters per minute now remember this is a
narrative only fifty percent heavier
than air but what it does next
but still stronger on the per weight
basis and steel I can show you
diffraction effects when there's stuff
being drawn from the yarn a forest but I
think it's better considering the time
if I thank you very much for your
attention
thank you for staying connected with
Carnegie Mellon University to learn more
go to WWE mu edu
you